ready quittant pas trop petits coeurs
majali tétreault service
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mon cerveau tu sais que ça
la musique
les projecteurs sur quoi ces flics
orochi vie devant elle la plus belle
demoiselle que moi j'aurais fait pas
bien jette le passé c'est le passé mais
entre nous je peux pas dire ce qui s'est
passé
foot pour vous rattraper le temps pour
tout parti moi qu'est-ce que j'ai fait
bon sang qu'est ce que j'ai fait bon
sang que le français s'est passé mais il
ya 14 ans confié tu sais j entends déjà
zappé
qui comprend pas jetons petit coeur moi
séries tu es trop séduisante était le
chouchou j'aime pas ce qui s'est passé
je pense à changer
qu est-ce qui s'est vu dire
j'aime bien des fois c'est chez toi tu
joues et jetez pas publiés
des manchots jetaient pas des fois c est
la plus belle des études parmi les
autres je vois que toi si tu te sens à
10 mois et s'offrait deux mois les
projecteurs sur toi c'est fou comme tu
me donnes moi est la plus belle
mademoiselle qu'orange aurait fait pas
de fautes tu as quelque chose
pour te comprends mais plus du tout
comment cacher parce qu'ils se cachent
de redonner foi jet pack moi je suis q
med res le premier dans ton coeur si les
maisons
cette pensée mais ya que toi je peux
confier tu sais cher
des fois quand je serai seul 10 ans
et ça a fait clic
qui comprend pas
toujours j'ai pas suisse se passer
koussa
[Musique]
sévigny la pelouse gelée bien
chez toi tu souhaiterais accompli
avec
m
[Applaudissements]
c'est possible